[Musique]
ne serait-ce le souffle feutré de
quelques bicyclette paris poursuivrait
encore à cette heure sa grasse matinée
dominicale seulement voilà ce
dimanche-là 20 mai toute la france avait
décidé de porter aux nues la petite
reine des moyens de transport l'occasion
pour l'amateur acharné comme pour le
nouvel adepte de manifester son
attachement à la bicyclette et de
participer par exemple à l'un des six
rallyes organisés à son intention
traversée de paris rallye en étoile
premiers pas cyclotouristique etc
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai une question
c'est l'info que je découvre roger a
nightmare villalonga
quant à refaire
donc je n'ai pas l'impression d'être un
peu une provinciale à paris aujourd'hui
ah oui aujourd'hui oui dans paris je
pense que j'aurai beaucoup leur pari
maraîchage en banlieue genre faire
vacances on savait non non non je suis
remonté sur un vélo j'ai parmi des
récits for hope est d'accord on est
parti de l'équipe de france
du procès ici et maintenant
à belleville
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
refroidis jeunes tambours
comment ça se passait très bien fait cad
hélas beaucoup de perdu 1 derrière sans
arrêt du tonnerre
passez une bonne journée le point la vie
est belle tu as quel âge tu dis ça c'est
la première fois qu'il fait la journée
nationale de la bicyclette
bonjour madame quand ça se passe cette
journée les pages qui peut vite m'ont
fait sinon tu peux parfait mais pas
choisi une épreuve difficile là vous
avez l'habitude dit tout c'est la
première fois vous fais du vélo depuis
le début de l'année non mais depuis le
début de l'année du début d'année oui
première fois et d'en parler vous en
ferez jamais pourquoi pas ce que je fais
ma petite maison à la campagne alors je
me permets de faire du vélo à la
campagne et sinon dans pareil ça vous
revient pas de la vie
l'émission de tf1 monsieur que qu'est ce
qui se passe ici
bien qu est ce qui se passe pas un
rassemblement pour le départ des tandems
issus d'un groupe de non voyants
c'est à dire par tandem celui de voir ya
un vide qui voit que ce soit fait
derrière un non voyant et mon coéquipier
là qu'est monsieur gilles bayard d'un
aveugle complet et il a toujours
pratiqué le tandem a longtemps fait deux
choses il fait du tandem et puis du ski
de fond même du ski alpin des hommes des
femmes des jeunes que rien n'arrête dont
leur volonté de rouler sinon parfois et
il est bon de savoir le manque de
pilotes bénévoles prêts à les guider
allait sortir un moment du tunnel sur
deux roues
[Musique]
révélation on découvre tout à coup ce
que l'on tait à montmartre venir
[Musique]
montmartre d'où les touristes étrangers
et repartiront peut-être ce jour là avec
la ferme conviction que tous les
parisiens ou presque circulant à
bicyclette en vue de quelques sombres
périodes de pénurie
une fois effectué leurs divers rallye
promenade plusieurs milliers de
participants devaient donc se diriger
vers l'avenue de la grande-armée avenue
transformé pour l'occasion en véritable
vélodrome pendant près de sept heures
d'affilée jeunes amateurs ou
semi-professionnels tirée par les
entraîneurs poussé par les parents y ont
rivalisé de vitesse représente pour vous
cette journée nationale à venir aux
champs elysées peut-être que ça se fait
jamais dans notre vie mais ce n'est là
que l'une des nombreuses facettes de la
bicyclette comme le souligne gérard
morel représentant sport pour tous
aujourd'hui nous sommes efforcés en tant
que direction départementale de la
jeunesse et des sports de paris de
rassembler le plus d'initiatives
possible nous avons cherché la diversité
que pour prouver que la forme
sport pour tous il voulait répond un
très grand d'éventails de besoins
ressentis par tous les adultes
sport pour tous en un mot pourrait se
définir comme que la promotion d'une
nouvelle valeur la condition physique et
ça roule ça roule aux quatre chemins de
la région parisienne de rueil malmaison
à fontenay-sous-bois du perreux à
bures-sur-yvette ça roule pour la
promenade pour la santé ou pour rire
comme ici au raincy
[Musique]
ouais
au pivot et leur piquer mon vélo
le gros une batteuse ont d'ailleurs au
coeur du bois de vincennes les pistards
de la cipale sus inlassablement les
mêmes kilomètres de béton tandis qu'une
course locale déroule son pointillés de
bernard hinault en puissance
et paisiblement l'hélicoptère de la
gendarmerie nationale regagne les portes
de paris et l'avenue de la grande armée
pacifique des cyclistes
une avenue mobilisé presque sans
interruption par l'esprit de compétition
ce qui explique sans doute que les
cyclotouristes grand initiateur de cette
fête nationale de la bicyclette par
l'intermédiaire de leurs fédérations
rester quelque peu à l'écart notamment
par refus pur et simple de se laisser
manger eux aussi à la sauce publicité
ce dimanche là un garçon de 15 ans et
demi entraîné depuis l'âge de 9 ans
inscrivait une 43e victoire à son
palmarès
tu viens de gagner de remporter des
cadeaux c'est important pour toi la
compétition bien sûr parce que je
devrais en faire si possible un métier
et qu'est ce que tu penses du
cyclotourisme bah c'est très bien mais
lyon que
nous pour les jeunes ne s'intéressent
pas beaucoup parce que c'est pas pareil
on préfère le sport 2
le gaillard plan vélo las et fatigué on
est responsable et fort entre temps les
cyclistes de tous poils ont convergé non
sans quelques peines vers l'arc de
triomphe
[Applaudissements]
sa bicyclette c'est pas de la rigolade
et les gens qui en font un peu
sérieusement mais moi qui ont fait pas
très sérieusement on en bave
moi j'ai mal aux fesses au bout de
combien de temps plus que d'ailleurs aux
jambes et puis et puis on en bave mais
je vois que tous les gens qui en bavent
à la fin quand ils ont fourni
il ya une satisfaction extraordinaire
parmi ces cyclotouristes qui prennent
petit à petit possession de l'avenue
georges grâce aux skis apôtres depuis
des années de l'écologie georges qui
s'apprête à partir pour un tour d'europe
de quatre mois à bicyclette cela va sans
dire et puis ça va dans le sens de
l'économie
et ce ne sera pas votre premier voyage
dont seulement que j'avais paris athènes
palais maximou et cette année c'est le
tour de l'europe c'est l'année
européenne le faire le déplacer pour le
départ c'est pour 5 juin c'est à dire
c'est la journée mondiale de l'eau
combien de participants cette année il
ya une vingtaine de tout âge 70 ans il
était bien naturel de profiter de cette
ambiance cyclotouristique pour proclamer
le résultat de notre concours bicyclette
est décerné les trente vélos offerts par
l'union nationale des deux roues
mika préférant mettre les pieds sur tout
le premier prix est un patient traité
avant de faire cette offre
c'est une charmante dame et la gagner
c'est dany couler c'est ce que de gaulle
à sanary
mm et puis il ya non seulement été
visionnaire mais il ya aussi des six
classes kacem la jolie la bicyclette les
toits qu'ils oublient que vous posiez gt
r c'est à nico de vous voilà donc la
grande gagnante de ce concours est ce
que ça a été difficile
ah oui j'ai beaucoup travaillé j'ai
étudié pas mal de revues d'art dans
l'eau bénite
je me suis donné de la peine qu'est ce
qui vous a posé plus de problèmes comme
question là c'est l'industrie du cycle
surtout parce que boom la sécurité
lorsqu'on la voiture où ces attentions
et une fois mécanique j'ai mon mari qui
m'a aidé alors c'était surtout
l'industrie du cycle c'était difficile
dites moi vous fait de la bicyclette
souvent beaucoup trop souvent j'aimerais
en faire plus mais hélas en travaillant
je n'ai pas le temps maintenant j'espère
remporter qu'un petit peu plus
vous êtes vous-même dans un milieu de
deux sites les champs du jour de ces
will mon mari s'occupe de cyclisme et
les moniteurs à sanary alors on a des
cyclistes du matin au soir la maison
[Musique]
vous les écologistes vous êtes
évidemment présents aujourd'hui mais
vous avez une notion bien particulière
de ce que pourrait être de scudder était
peut-être l'utilisation de la bicyclette
en ville
oui pour nous ce qui est important c'est
c'est surtout de pouvoir faire du vélo
normalement tous les jours
tranquillement comme d'autres comme aux
us marcher à pied d'ailleurs c'est
également très important mais le vélo
est particulièrement défavorisée
maintenance un petit peu a dévié le
point à bicyclette en le plaçant sur le
le loisir la compétition qui sont des
choses qui ont leur valeur mais ce n'est
pas tout bien sûr tout la vie de tous
les jours les déplacements ordinaire
pour aller au travail pour aller au
lycée s'est fait rare et là dessus sur
ces aspects quotidien est finalement
très important l'impression qu'ils en
oublient fâcheuses pour créer ce que
vous n'allez pas à l'école à bicyclette
car on ne l'est pas et pourquoi ne
veut-il pas parce qu'on a peur qu'on
soit mal mais qu'on se fasse écraser
pour les voitures quant au monde il ya
un danger
oui et vous aimeriez bien que ça change
when i was salariés puisque j'habite est
de plus en plus nettement défavorisés
la belle ville de paris monsieur guy
caby 30/10 skrela sortir de paris prend
là et je vais travailler tous les jours
en vélo m'a bien dangereuse en soi
problématique en effet cette place de la
bicyclette aujourd'hui en ville surtout
à moins que ne se généralise par exemple
est très vite
l'apprentissage de la circulation et ce
dès l'école maternelle
cette idée de village en réduction lancé
par la prévention routière fonctionne
déjà à titre expérimental dans une
vingtaine de départements
une journée nationale de la bicyclette
c'est bien c'est formidable et même si
les conditions atmosphériques ont
découragé quelques peu les participants
et l'année j'ai par exemple à
saint-etienne et bien cette quatrième
manifestation marquera d'une pierre
blanche la fabuleuse histoire du vélo à
condition toutefois de ne pas négliger
pendant les 364 autres jours
un moyen de transport et de loisirs qui
n'a pas fini de faire parler de lui
[Musique]
si vous pensez qu'on peut faire l'europe
du vélo exactement
vive la vélorution
[Musique]